[Musik]
fragen und antworten zum thema name
wohnort
herkunft
und ab
guten tag
ich bin euer deutschlehrer
mein name ist leandro
mein familienname ist bella rosa
guten tag
ich bin euer deutschlehrer
mein name ist leandro
mein familienname ist bella rosa
ich bin 41 jahre alt
wie heißt du
und wie alt bist du
ich heiße li na
ich bin
27 jahre jung
ich heiße li na
ich bin 27 jahre jung
mein name ist michael
mein geburtstag ist der vierzehnte
oktober
mein name ist michael
mein geburtstag ist der vierzehnte
oktober
ich bin thomas
ich bin am 13 juli
1980 in italien geboren
ich bin thomas
ich bin am 3 juli
1980 in italien geboren
mein vorname ist anna
ich bin 22 jahre alt
mein geburtstag ist am ersten august
mein vorname ist anna
schön euch alle kennen zu lernen
der erste august ist übrigens der
nationalfeiertag der schweiz
[Musik]
welchen tag feierst du in deinem land
welchen tag feiert du in deinem land
ich freue mich auf deine antwort in den
kommentaren
ich bin in der schweiz geboren und
aufgewachsen
ich bin in der schweiz
und aufgewachsen
woher kommst du
ich komme aus spanien
jetzt lebe und arbeite ich aber in der
schweiz
ich komme aus spanien
jetzt lebe und arbeite ich aber in der
schweiz
ich wo in deutschland
ich komme aber ursprünglich aus
frankreich
ich wo in deutschland
ich komme aber ursprünglich aus
frankreich
meine familie kommt aus italien
ich lebe aber mit meiner frau in
österreich
meine familie kommt aus italien
ich lebe aber mit meiner frau in
österreich
wo genau lebt er in österreich
wir wohnen
in wien
das ist die hauptstadt von österreich
wir wohnen in wien
wien ist eine wunderschöne stadt
da gibt es viel zu entdecken
meine großeltern
kommen aus london
ich lebe aber seit einem jahr in berlin
meine großeltern
kommen aus london
ich liebe aber seit einem jahr in berlin
lebst du gerne in berlin
ich liebe es in berlin zu wohnen
ich liebe in berlin zu wohnen
das ist sehr spannend
ihr seid eine tolle gruppe
ich freue mich auf weitere lektionen mit
euch
und woher kommst du
schreibe es unten in die kommentare
und was denkst du über den deutschkurs
bei der halo deutsch schule
mir gefällt der kurs sehr gut
und was denkst du über den deutschkurs
bei der halo deutsch schule
mir gefällt der kurs sehr gut
was mir aber besonders gut gefällt ist
unser deutschlehrer
leandro ist ein sehr attraktiver mann
was du nicht sagst
das ist mir auch aufgefallen
leider ist er aber schon vergeben
er ist verheiratet und hat zwei söhne
das ist schade er
wäre genau mein typ gewesen
ich hoffe das video war hilfreich für
dich
hier nochmals die zehn wichtigsten
fragen aus diesem video
wie heißt du
wie ist dein vorname
wie ist dein nachname
woher kommst du
wohnst du
wo liegt das
wie alt bist du
wann bist du geboren
wo bist du geboren
wann ist dein geburtstag
dann ist dein geburtstag
fallen dir noch weitere fragen ein
schreiben sie uns in die kommentare
bis zum nächsten mal
vergisst das video zu leiden
[Musik]
kommentiere und abonniere unseren kanal